hola
mm hi I'm studying in cos were this year
but today I've got the day off
I'd like to show you the city so come on
bubbles
again I'm on top of the connoisseur
palace and the first thing that you'll
notice about the city is the way the
streets are laid out they all start out
here they call it the fan-shaped city
because that's what it looks like
oh yes okay Danny got through it
thank you sir well another great thing
about council is that it has a lot of
trees when the leaves change color in
the fall it's beautiful
we're moss
yeah this is the Art Center
Thunder one it's remarkable this
building doesn't look like much from the
outside but inside it's pretty amazing
let's have a look mom okay
k-11 contrada hey Tom I better sit this
is unusual but it's also fun when you
play around with the simulation do you
feel like a kid again
well rather than me it's great it's
almost like you can really touch the
bubbles Lavoie drew holla lsat gazette
Khayyam Art Center is very special
well McDonnell so you never know what
you're going to find around the next
corner but aunty particulary this is
pretty realistic I really feel like I'm
flying to a city also something on that
the goo no but it's tougher than it
looks
Emily Fessenden okay Marisa
miss meghamala german markets are really
well-organized compared to the ones we
have in chile you saw a movie
phonetically and miss Collins Chile oh
that was a rodeo circuit it's really
something to be able to buy bread at a
market a career I've never done that
before
look at the selection
yep there's the time back our last stop
well start then working luckily you
don't have to climb up there they've got
a cable railway
that's steep oh nice I got and moving
what a great view
why don't I climb was really worth it
yeah okay you can see all of Kyle's who
are from up here
we're not man to end our tour of cars
hooah I'll leave you with this
spectacular view uh-oh
you